all right let's talk about this covid
story because this is pretty shocking
Kentucky Senator Rand Paul officially
sending a criminal referral for Dr
Anthony fauci to the justice department
claiming a newly released email sent by
fauci in February of 2020 contradicts
his 2021 testimony during a covid-19
hearing fauci wrote in part quote
scientists in Wuhan University are known
to have been working on gain of function
experiments associated with bat viruses
adapting to human infection and the
outbreak originated in Wuhan this comes
as Dr fauci's former boss suggests the
former White House advisor might have
silenced the science on the Wuhan lab to
protect his own reputation Sky News host
Sherry markson broke the story in the
Australian and she joins us now good
morning to you
good morning Ainsley great to be with
you well great to have you on I read the
whole article what a gat you interviewed
Anthony fauci's boss his name is Robert
kadlek he's the former assistant
secretary for preparedness and response
at the U.S Department of Health and he
created operation warp speed what
exactly did he tell you that you found
to be so shocking
look there were two things that really
were quite shocking the first is that he
directly said that Anthony fauci decided
to protect his own reputation and the
reputation of his Institute which was
funding this risky coronavirus gain of
function research at the Wuhan Institute
of virology and that's why Anthony
Anthony fauci was motivated to downplay
any suggestions of a lab lick and they
had these conversations deliberately
deciding to downplay the rhetoric about
the origins of the virus while they were
trying to find out where it came from
and encourage cooperation with Beijing
so this was you know in Robert
Cadillac's own admission this is a
deliberate decision to deflect attention
away from the Wuhan lab and he says he
thinks Anthony vouchi was trying to
protect his own interests the second
part to this Ainsley that was so
fascinating is that Robert Kadlec said
that their investigation indicate that
it was vaccine research by the Chinese
military in conjunction with the Wuhan
Institute of virology that they think
led to the creation and outbreak of
covert 19.
you also write I've always wondered why
he was telling us telling Americans how
we need to respond to this to this virus
meanwhile he worked for the National
Institutes of Health and other U.S
agencies that were giving money to this
lab for gain of function research you
write in your article that he funded 65
projects or the National Institute of
Health and other U.S agencies funded 65
projects at the Wuhan Institute of
virology over the past decade you also
say that some of these doctors Dr fauci
the man that you interviewed Robert
kadlek and Francis Collins privately
talked about how to how to turn down the
temperature on vest to deliberately
decide to downplay suspicions from
scientists that coveted came from a lab
tell me more about that
so this is before the group of
international scientists held that phone
call on the 1st of February where they
in effect decided to say that covid-19
didn't have a laboratory origin even
though many of them privately suspected
that it did and we know that because of
emails that have been subpoenaed by U.S
Congress but ahead of that call Robert
kadlick said in his discussions with
Francis Collins and with Anthony fauci
that they wanted to turn down the
rhetoric on suggestions that the virus
came from a lab or was a bioweapon or
was engineered and you know he he says
it's partly to protect Anthony's
reputation from his perspective from
Robert kadlick's he was trying to get
China to share a sample of the virus so
he didn't want these public accusations
flying and Ainsley you know while on one
level you can understand that on another
this is incredibly misleading and it's
been a great deception on the whole
public the whole world and and it's also
misleading advice that then went to the
intelligence community that went to our
policy makers and to the media yeah they
also talked about it being possibly
genetically engineered which is pretty
scary if this was deliberate in a lab
which ended up resulting in so many
deaths around the world why I'm curious
why did he decide to talk to you what is
the purpose in this
look I've written a book what really
happened in Wuhan so I've been very
committed to investigating the topic of
the origins of covid-19 and specifically
investigating the Wuhan Institute of
rology since April 2020 so more than
three years now I've interviewed a lot
of I mean hundreds of people on this
topic on and off the Record so I asked
Robert kadlick to speak with me he did
it first off the Record and
because I was writing this investigative
feature the weekend Australian magazine
but it's just part of my more than
three-year investigation to this topic
I'm deeply committed to finding out the
origin of the pandemic because seven
million people have died and I do not
believe that politicians in the United
States in the Australia in Australia or
anywhere else have done enough to to ask
Beijing to open up the lab to hold them
to account and to find out what happened
we all want to know Sherry thank you so
much
thank you very much welcome we do have
Senator Rand Paul he's going to join us
later this morning we're going to talk
to him about this and find out what
happens next
I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and
I'm Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis